Speaker 1: . And finally, for this week for
me, we got to talk even more, unfortunately,
about the Turning Point USA Conference
because there's one last thing from that
that I want to discuss that is truly terrifying,
and that is Madison Cawthorn during his speech.
Started talking about civil war and how if
we have another civil war, which he swears
he doesn't want, but if we have one man,
conservatives are totally going to win it.
Here's what he says. We patriotic Americans
because Republicans hold a monopoly on patriotism.
We're born for such a time as this. We're going
to face some dark times as a nation. I genuinely
believe that I think we have an opportunity in
the next four to six years to prevent kinetic
force countrymen on countrymen from ever meeting.
Although I have no doubt we would be victorious
if that would ever happen. But remember, there
would be so immoral and wrong if we said, Hey,
you know what? Let's kick off a civil war and
then we'll just go ahead and go to that point.
It's time for us to stop being sheep and stand up
and be lions, the radical left should be terrified
of who we are. The radical left should
be terrified of what we are going to do.
We are. We absolutely are. Because we've
seen what you do. We've seen what your kind
does. They stormed the Capitol. The assault police
officers while storming the Capitol. They call in
death threats to secretaries of state because they
don't like the election results of that state.
They call in so many death threats to certain
members of Congress that they've had to undergo
special training. On how to handle these things.
They issue racist and bigoted threats to them on
the floor of the House of Representatives. Do I
need to go on? Or do you get the picture here?
Yeah, that's what terrifies us. It terrifies us
that this is becoming normalized and it's becoming
normalized by people like Madison Cawthorn himself
also in his little speech there. He encouraged
people to drop out of college. Tory young
conservatives, if you're not going to be a doctor,
lawyer, engineer, just drop out. It's a scam, he
said. He dropped out and he turned out just fine.
Yeah. So fine, by the way, that he is running
for Congress in a different district next year
because his current district is turning
blue and he knows he can't win, so he has
to switch over to a different one in order
to, you know, keep his job that he clearly
is not qualified or even
rational enough to be holding.
Before I go today, I want to take another
moment here to thank David to think Pat,
think everybody with The David Pakman Show
for giving me this opportunity. The week of
Christmas to fill in to be here with you. I think
everybody who tuned in to this and of course,
if you've enjoyed me and even if not, you
should probably still do this. You can subscribe
to my YouTube channels youtube.com slash the ring
of fire and youtube.com slash fair and balanced.
You can catch me every week on the Ring of
Fire podcast, R O F podcast, dot com, Twitter,
Facebook and Instagram at fair and balanced. I
hope everyone has a wonderful holiday weekend.
Whether you celebrate or not. Take some time.
Enjoy it. Have some good food. Relax. And wait
for the new year to begin. I'm Farron Cousins
Unidentified: and David Pakman, thank you for.